l'agence de notation fit donc donne une
note qui reste excellente quand même
pour la France on est donc classé AA
alors la meilleure des notes c'est AAA
il faut quand même savoir que la France
avait cette note ce triple A jusqu'en
2012 2013 et ensuite les trois
principales agences de notation ont
dégradé la note de la France ça c'est
quand même plutôt inquiétant parce que
ça plutôt tendance à baisser c'est pas
la joie ah ouais c'est pas la joie ça se
voit pour expliquer son choix là je
prends mes notes l'agence de notation
évoque je cite l'impasse politique et
les mouvements sociaux entre parenthèses
parfois violents alors évidemment c'est
alors ça c'est important les mots sont
forts impasse politique le rendez-vous a
été donné de longues dates aujourd'hui
partout en France 300 rassemblement des
manifestations qui ont débuté dès ce
matin notamment à Toulouse Rennes
Marseille et Lyon où la tradition est
respectée
mais derrière cette ambiance bonne
enfant la colère gronde
famine pâte riz c'est ce qui nous attend
avec Macron et elle est dirigée contre
un seul homme
elle est aussi rapide kabyle dans
l'esquive
[Musique]
résultat plus de 2 millions de
manifestants en France selon la CGT 782
000 selon le ministère de l'intérieur
c'est deux fois plus que la dernière
mobilisation contre les retraites le 13
avril dernier et quasiment 7 fois plus
qu'il y a un an à la même date saucisse
[Musique]
regardez notamment ces images qui
circulent et c'est très récent en ça
concerne la réforme des retraites un
internaute qui a organisé une petite
manif place de la Concorde dans les rues
de Paris grâce au jeu Mario Kart alors
ils sont pas hyper nombreux on va passer
il y a pas de casserole là
800000 personnes qui ont vu cette vidéo
est là pour le coup on est sûr du
chiffre et ça c'est le jeu Animal
Crossing où là aussi il y a une petite
manif soutient au grévistes avec un
panneau de la CGT on est tous là pour
refuser de se faire voler deux ans de
vie que personne ne l'oublie on ne
passera pas autre chose parce qu'on ne
peut pas passer à autre chose de sa
propre vie ce n'est pas possible mais
quand je commence à entendre partout
Macron démission ce n'est plus un mot
d'ordre d'avant garde ça commence à
devenir un désir et une espérance
populaire de masse si beau le H est un
de celui qui en a plein les bottes oui
oui
dans le cortège certains manifestent
pour la première fois comme cette
professeur retraitée qui a tenu à faire
entendre sa voix
passe sans notre avis
et je pense que c'est important
important de donner notre avis qui
conçoit c'est ça la démocratie ce soir
les autorités annoncent 90
interpellations certaines grâce au drone
de la police déployée à Paris mais aussi
à Lyon où les parapluies étaient de
sortie pour échapper à leur caméra
vous savez quoi comme Internet
c'est vous qui filmez pendant toute la
manette vous êtes comme nous vous avez
des caméras
vous avez les drones aussi aujourd'hui
non
il y a une différence entre la
contestation et quand vous coupez de
l'électricité dans un stade de 14000
personnes lorsqu’un n'est pas des touché
lorsque il y a une enquête qui est en
cours s'il y a une clinique a été
touchée il y a deux semaines si vous
parlez pas de rail des canalisations
prenons le prenons un autre dictionnaire
CGT c'est bon on l'a compris
avant on avait un moustachu et un des
garni on a aujourd'hui deux femmes 40
heures est-ce que vous leur dites merci
avis Martinez et à Laurent Berger on
leur dit qu'il y a déjà eu beaucoup de
progrès capillaires n'est-ce pas c'est
en faisant toutes leurs places aux
femmes dans les organismes nous allons
débattre en inter syndicale des moyens
de maintenir la mobilisation jusqu'au 8
juin prochain pour gagner l'abrogation
de cette loi à l'Assemblée nationale 8
juin date à laquelle l'assemblée devra
se prononcer sur une proposition
d'abrogation de la réforme d'ores et
déjà la gauche se dit prête à poursuivre
la bataille parlementaire
on entame la guérilla dès le 3 mai on
est loin des clichés qu'on peut avoir du
syndicalisme poussiéreux homme des
cavernes enfin voilà on est on est
moderne on est quand même et on est les
voilà on est une femme d'image juste un
mécanisme leur travail ça vient du latin
tripalium alors tri ces trois palium
c'est pieux donc tripalium trois pieux
alors pourquoi parce que les Romains
utilisaient trois pieux pour fabriquer
un horrible instrument torture bon alors
on peut chercher des illustrations sur
le net mais attendez d'avoir digéré
votre petit déjeuner je vois pas
vraiment le rapport avec le travail là
mais parce que à cause du instrument de
torture c'était la souffrance et ça
l'est encore c'est 5 milliards d'euros
d'impôts le groupe Bernard Arnault avec
200 000 emplois créés
donc s'il te plaît j'en voudrais
beaucoup des Bernard Arnaud en France je
voudrais énormément de Bernard Arnaud
chaque milliards il les payent d'impôts
de taxes de TVA de contribution en
France que dans un autre pays les
babouins perchés tout en haut de l'arbre
laisse tomber quelques fruits
[Musique]
geste de coopération solidaire
les scientifiques n'ont pas encore percé
ce mystère quand Platon en grec ancien
dit tous les veaux ça veut dire je
souffre et quand Costa gavrase dit tous
les veaux en grec moderne le même mot ça
veut dire je travaille donc visiblement
le travail ça a d'abord été de la
souffrance quand même un petit lien
entre les deux t'imagines qu'il y a 480
taxes et un pot différent
de taxes et tu me dis non la France on
paye pas assez d'impôts
et Madame les écoles sont dans un état
lamentable les hôpitaux sont dans des
Alpes
ne déclenche aucun réflexe de
concurrence
il offre à chacun un rarement
d'abondance